we have to get to some very disturbing
new video for mama June's reunion show
yeah you know sometimes it feels like
this stuff is staged but there seems to
be no faking this vicious confrontation
between sugar bear you got a pumpkin
okay I swear got you - I got you -
sugar bear got so angry he tore his
shirt off and pumpkin who stepped in to
defend her mom had to be held back huh
swear to God I will be the drama started
when Mama June claims sugar bear wasn't
involved in honey Boo Boo's life was lit
up it was every weekend every every
weekend I was up see Alana and it was
going good and then you talking about
well we're gonna be busy this weekend
we're gonna be out of time but I'll tell
you what I got a lawyer on vacation you
gonna get the paperwork paperwork for
what all I got think we've learned sugar
bear is asking for visitation rights by
the way while all of this was unfolding
honey boo boo was backstage safe and
unaware of what was happening her dad
told us quote I've tried to stay in
touch with my daughter but June won't
let me well sugar bear friendly happy is
he happy oh when we sat down with mama
June and honey boo boo recently they
described a strained relationship with
sugar bear what's your relationship like
now with sugar bear it's not existent I
didn't even know what to say to her
time for the professionals to step in oh
yeah this fan no doubt about that
[Music]